in california and across the u.s the
covid 19 numbers
are staggering in los angeles county
population
10 million there were fewer than 100
intensive care unit beds available on
tuesday
in some areas like the central valley
and counties east of los angeles
there are zero icu beds left
more people will die because the whole
health the
care system is overwhelmed statewide
more than 42 thousand cases
of covet 19 were reported on monday
breaking all previous single day records
we're still in the tunnel going through
the most
challenging and difficult surge we've
experienced since the beginning
of this pandemic most of the state is
under a stay at home order
still public officials pleaded with
people to wear masks
and socially distance we just had to
order 5 000 additional body bags they
just purchased for the state
that should be sobering after more than
three hundred thousand
deaths nationwide millions of doses of
pfizer's vaccine are now being
distributed around the country
with medical workers at the front of the
line
more encouraging news came from the u.s
food and drug administration
which found moderna's vaccine candidate
to be 94 percent
effective emergency fda authorization
for the vaccine is expected by the end
of the week
a new poll shows 71 percent of the u.s
population wants to get vaccinated right
away
that's an 8 percent increase from
september widespread vaccine acceptance
is
essential to combating the virus vaccine
rollout also
costs money congress is still working on
multi-billion dollar coveted relief
legislation
but they're not there yet no matter how
long
it takes we'll be here until we get a
covered package
the country's top infectious disease
expert dr anthony fauci
recommended that president-elect joe
biden who is 78 years old
and vice president-elect kamala harris
get vaccinated right away
in the interests of national security
you want him
fully protected as he enters into the
presidency
in january so that would be my strong
recommendation
biden said he'd take that advice when i
do it you'll have noticed
and will do it publicly much of the
ongoing nationwide surge is attributed
to virus exposure during travel and
family
gatherings over the thanksgiving holiday
last month
with hanukkah underway and christmas
coming next week
doctors are begging americans to stay
home
and stay safe rob reynolds al jazeera
los angeles